Alhamdulillah. He was
[Silence]
Today inshallah
we are going to be speaking about a very
pertinent topic
with regards to
common superstitions.
Whether those superstitions be in the
issue of omens, the issue of luck,
superstitions with regards to
astrology,
superstitions with regards to magicians,
soothsayers, fortune tellers, fortune
cookies.
issues with regards to
mediums who allegedly speak to the dead
for us,
etc., etc.
Now, this is our series. Of course,
we're not going to be able to get to all
of that today,
but we are going to be speaking about
these issues, issues of hauntings,
things that have been instilled in us,
especially here in America, but all over
the world really.
Things that have been instilled in us
for
decades, even centuries or millennia.
It's always been around and a kind of
stain on the heart of the human being.
And these things all
coincide
in particular definitions.
Now these superstitions that we're going
to mention are so numerous there is no
way we could ever mention all of them.
However, the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and before that in the Quran,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has given us
certain principles and certain
definitions that we can go by
and we base
our understanding of the present
on these past definitions that were
given to us.
Now the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did mention certain types of
certain types of superstitions.
Yeah. certain types of superstitions
which were
around in his time. Sallallah.aii
wasallam.
Things that were common to his time,
things that were known to his time.
And these examples
again, they fall into the general
definition that was given to us. But
those particular examples or instances
that were around in his time su alaihi
wasallam those things are obviously
dated. There are some things that have
changed outwardly but at their essence
and at their core they are the same.
These things have not changed.
Today, inshallah, what we want to speak
about is something that is referred to
in the Quran and in the Sunnah as
what is this? Well,
the scholars of Islam have mentioned
that
it is a method or a belief system that
was around in the time of
the superstitious
nations and the nations of paganism and
idolatry
that they believed that certain things
articulated
particular events to happen or not.
And there were particular animals which
were considered bad omens.
There were particular animals which were
considered good omens.
There were particular times of the day,
of the week, of the month, of the year
that are considered bad luck times.
And we'll get into some examples of
this. So is the belief system
is the actual
implica implementation
of these beliefs. So for example, to
believe
that a black cat is bad luck. This is
called a to.
And then to walk down the road and have
a black cat cross your path and then you
decide, you know what, I'm going to just
call it a day and go back home before
something bad happens. This is
and this is what we're going to speak
about today, inshallah.
examples of this. Again, in order for us
to properly understand this and not just
give a bunch of random examples,
we have to be able to define something
because when we define something, we now
have a particular understanding and
authority over it. This is why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks about Adam
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala taught
Adam the names the names of everything
because when he gave Adam the knowledge
of these names this gave Adamis a
particular understanding and authority
and power over these things.
And so
is something that or is something that
has been around
again as we've mentioned a kind of stain
on the heart of humanity. It's always
there. And the reason is is that these
things come from a shaitan. He injects
doubts into our minds.
These doubts are then brewed over and
they are pined over until they become
beliefs. And then we start to look for
something that is called in psychology
confirmation bias. Which means that once
we believe something, we start to look
for it and we start to look for
evidences of this confirmation bias.
This is
the problem with
is that it begins in the heart as a
whisper of aan.
Then these things are brewed over. They
are pined over.
They are pined over until they become
beliefs. And then we start as human
beings. We have this confirmation bias
where we start to look for evidences of
it.
Right? And these things are still
around. They are present amongst
Muslims. They are present amongst
non-Muslims. We find them in
all around us in billboards, in
buildings, in elevators, in in things
that people say, things that people do,
right? such as knock on wood or find
a penny, pick it up or these things that
we have in America that we'll speak
about as well. these things are
constantly being pushed upon us in
media, in movies, movies of hauntings, a
place where a murder took place or
someone committed suicide, this place is
somehow now ominous, etc., etc.
Now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
mentioned
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has mentioned
in the Quran
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentioned this
and he ascribed this belief
to
the mushri the enemies of the prophets
and messengers.
those who were disbelievers in the
prophets and messengers.
For instance, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions this with regards to
Allah mentions in the seventh
chapter of the Quran in verse 131.
[Silence]
This translates to speaking about
Pharaoh and his followers and Misam and
his followers.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says with
regards to Pharaoh and his followers,
but when good times came, they said this
is due to us. Meaning whenever something
good would happen, they would
essentially ascribe this to their own
earnings. Rather than saying this is
from the mercy of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, they would ascribe it to their
own efforts. We deserve this. We are
good people. This affirms that we are
upon the truth and Misam and his
followers are upon misguidance and
falsehood. Why? Because they use what
they perceive to be good
as an evidence to validate their
actions.
Again, as we mentioned, confirmation
bias. This is this is the problem when
we believe a certain thing and then
we start to look for evidences of it.
So this will reflect what people exalt
in their in their lives. So for example,
in a materialistic society, people will
exalt wealth, material possessions.
And so we will see people that are very
wealthy or people that have been
given fame or success or whatever they
consider to be good. Even though it it
it is not necessarily good just because
it makes you feel good or just because
it validates you. That is not the yard
stick of good and evil. However,
a person may
consider fame or wealth or any of
these things to be good.
And then when they get these things,
when they receive these things, they
take their receiving of these things as
a validation to their actions.
So they're saying,
"I am upon good because I have been
given this thing that I consider and
hold to be good. This is a validation of
what I am upon."
Right? And the opposite as well. a
person loses money, if a person is faced
with something they consider to be a
tragedy or they consider to be negative.
Again, not everything that makes you
feel bad is is negative. That is not the
yard stick of negativity.
However,
in this person's mind, this particular
event or this particular calamity or
this particular emotion
is something that they hold to be bad.
they hold to be negative and then they
will use this as an evidence to validate
whatever it is they have believed that I
should not do this because this is this
is making me feel this way or I should
not do this because every time I do it
something bad happens right this is not
the yard stick of our journey to Allah
and our understanding objectively
understanding of our environment and the
universe around
and more importantly
learning about Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and his names and attributes and the
things that he decrees and the things
that he does. We do not learn in this
way. and so it is
important that a person define things as
defined by the Quran and Sunnah as
defined divinely as defined by Allah and
his messengers.
And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions with
regards to Pharaoh and his followers,
but when good times came, they said this
is due to us.
When gripped by calamity, they ascribed
it to evil omens connected with Moses
and those with him.
In truth, the omens of evil are theirs
in Allah's sight, but most of them do
not understand.
And so what is meant here is that when
something they perceive to be good,
something that they exalt or
something that they hold in high esteem
occurs or happens or is achieved, they
will ascribe this to mean that this is a
validation of what we are upon
of worship of other than Allah, of
association of partners unto Allah, the
worship of man, whatever it is. And
whenever something that they perceived
to be bad would occur,
they would point the finger outward.
They would point the finger at Musam and
they would say, "Because you guys are in
our midst, because you live with us,
because you are in our communities, you
are bringing bad omens with you."
And so they looked for validation of
what they already believed. And this is
really the heart of the issue, isn't it?
That people will look for validation
in that which they already believe, for
validation of what they already believe.
And so
Allah subhana wa ta'ala responds to this
and says, "In truth, the omens of evil
are theirs in Allah's sight." Meaning
the bad things that are happening to
them that are truly bad things this is
the cause of these bad things are their
actions their disobedience to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that is really the
ascend essence of the issue
and so this is what we mentioned here as
now why is it called
it is referred to this
in the Arabic language because of a
belief
which became so connected to a
particular omen that it took on that
name. And this happens a lot when a
particular brand name for instance
takes on this this this
genre or this particular
set of things
our mind is drawn to one particular
thing. So for example, if we look at
certain things that are mean
something in our language, for
example, if I say
Xerox something, I'm going to Xerox
something. Well, Xerox is a brand name
of a copier company. And we have that
brand name has become so prominent that
it has become the verb that we use even
though there are other types of copers
canon and whatever else there is right
and so this is the same kind of thing
here when we have something a it's
originally taken from a very particular
type of omen and that is an omen with
regards to
and that is an omen that the Arabs
believed the pagans believed the
idoltors in the time of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
believed with regards to birds
specifically and particular types of
birds and we have that today these
stigmas are still around with regards
to these particular types of animals. So
they believed especially birds the
crow,
vultures,
these types of birds, right? Owls, bats,
these particular, and I know bats, they
fly. That's what I mean. Birds. These
particular
types of animals
held very specific bad omens in the
minds of the idoltors at the time. And
so they would look to the actions of
these birds. If they would see a bird
perched somewhere,
they may throw a stone or scare or
startle this bird. And then when
startling the bird, they would observe
which direction the bird would go.
According to them, if it went to the
right, that is a good omen. If it went
to the left, that is a bad omen. And
they would actually use this as a kind
of gauge to make their decisions. Right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala replaced this
for us with
however what they would do is they're
getting ready to go out for the day or
go on to a go onto a journey, take a
trip somewhere. They would pack all
their stuff. They would say goodbye to
everyone, farewell, etc. They would
begin their journey outside of the city.
And on their way, the first bird or
birds that were still, they would
disturb these birds and observe how
these birds would react to their
disturbance. And so if the birds would
go to the right, they would continue on
in their journey. If the birds go to the
left, then they would turn around and go
back and say, "Better not
continue on with this journey today
because this is a bad omen
because this is considered a bad omen
for them. And so we see this is again
this is the most common type
of omen that was around at their time.
But it it is not restricted to only
birds and particular types of birds.
It's anything in America here.
something that has been around for a
long time is a black cat. Right? If a
black cat crosses your path that's bad
luck. That's that's that's not a good
sign, right? And black cats are always
held in superstitious you know
anytime if I say black cats usually our
mind goes to Halloweens and witches in
America.
Why? Because these are considered bad
omens. A black cat is considered to be
something that is holds a bad
meaning. And if a black cat crosses your
path, well, that's that's a terrible
omen. Or if you you know go into a
place and you find a black cat therein
or all kinds of superstitions are
attached to black cats in our in our
culture. And so
when we speak about omens,
we have to understand again that it's
not just about
what the times what the Arab pagans in
the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam believed. He gave us
definitions, general definitions
and then he pointed out particular
examples of that definition of those
definitions in his time, right? And so
really what a is
is that an individual
perceive bad omens
in people,
animals, creatures, particular places,
particular things that they hear,
particular phrases that are said,
particular things that they see
particular events that take place
or particular times,
particular
floors, anything of the creation of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that is
perceived as ominous
this falls into the generality of
this is what is right. So let's let's
take an example of that for instance.
Now
an example of this
in animals, creatures,
particular types of people,
right?
Particular animals. We gave an example
of black cats or crows or owls for
instance. Owls
are held in pagan pagan beliefs for
centuries if not millennia even back to
the time of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam which it was referred to as a h
and he said
in Bkari Muslim
mean owls do not bring bad luck. People
believe that an owl flying above your
house or if an owl makes a sound above
your house or lands on top of a person's
house in certain places even till today
but in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that this was
an evidence and an omen that death is
approaching right so if a if an owl
would land on top of someone's house and
you know I lived in the Caribbean for a
very long time and there. They still
believe this that if an owl circles over
your house or makes a sound over your
house or lands on top of your house,
even worse, this means somebody's going
to die in that house, right?
Or crows or vultures,
right? We're not speaking about vultures
following someone who is on death's
doorstep. vultures. They are looking for
something to eat and they eat carcasses.
This is what they do. They are
scavengers. This is not what we're
speaking about. We're speaking about
merely seeing them. Something that has
nothing to do with our reality, nothing
more than a whisper of a shaitan
being validated by our false beliefs.
This is what a is, right?
And so we have examples of that
the black cat that I mentioned, right?
Owls,
snakes,
right? That if you see a snake or if a
snake crosses your path, etc., etc.
Different places have different twists
and and spins on this particular idea,
but essentially they all join back to
the same belief system.
a same thing with places
right in popular culture especially in
you know a lot of Hollywood movies and
so forth we believe especially here in
America
that if a person dies in a particular
place
or if a person commits a murder in that
particular place a murder has happened
or if a suicide takes place or some kind
of tragedy in that house, this makes
this house
haunted.
This makes this house ominous. And so we
attach all kinds of beliefs to that. And
you know, we may think, oh, that's just
superstition. We don't really believe
it. It's just fun. But
honestly, these things have found their
way even into a into law. So, for
example, a realtor has to disclose
in particular states
that this house a murder occurred here
or a suicide or a haunting, right?
And this goes back to a saying that we
have where we say in America Amityville,
right? Amityville horror. This is an
Amityville
kind of situation. And what's meant by
that is the house that is in Amityville
in which a man murdered his family.
a son murdered his mother and father
and siblings right in this house. and
it's considered to be the most haunted
house in America, etc., etc. And this
all roots back to a belief that the soul
does not move on to judgment
upon death. Rather, this soul remains in
that house, in that space,
right? Until they are set free or until
they are released by whatever event in
the world happens. And this all roots
back to pagan beliefs.
that there is no judgment in the
hereafter.
That this world is somehow significant
enough that even death, something as as
serious as death, still revolves around
the events of this world, right? So a
person that dies has nothing better to
do than to haunt this particular
building, right? For
however long. And this is something that
the mushri believed in the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam as
well. Right? People even believe things
this person was killed unrightfully
and so the ghost the this person's
soul still inhibits this area or still
inhabits this area trying to give
evidences trying to solve their own
murder and give hints to, you know, as
if this person that died has nothing
better to do than to hang out in this
placeh for for the rest of time.
So they believe this in the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam they
believed that when a person was murdered
that this person was killed before his
time and that this person's soul would
not move on to you know would not would
not cease to be until this person was
avenged. This person's murder was
avenged until retribution is had. And so
they believe that owls
were birds that carried around the
souls of these people that are murdered
or these people that have died in this
particular place. And that this owl is
constantly
in the area or upon anniversaries the
day and time when this particular murder
happened. that this soul will always be
there, will always come out, we'll
scream, we'll yell, whatever it is until
vengeance is had, until they are
avenged. Right?
This is something that we believe
anytime you hear a superstition
with regards to a particular place, any
story, any story, I'm willing to tell
you 99.9%
of the time, any time when there is some
kind of, you know, alleged paranormal
activity or some kind of poltergeist
somewhere,
we'll find that in the story, in the
narrative, there is some backstory of a
murder or a tragedy or a death or what
have you, right?
likewise in America, another thing
that we believe is the 13th floor. Many
many
buildings, major buildings, skyscrapers
and major cities don't have a 13th
floor. It goes 1214. They skip 13
because the 13th floor is considered to
be ominous. in far east Asia many
airlines don't have a 13th row in their
airplanes because this is considered
something ominous right another thing
that people believe with regards to
numbers are lucky numbers right and you
get these lucky numbers even in
fortune cookies right all of This
according to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is a type of shik. It is
a type of association of partners unto
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said in the narration of Mas
which has been collected by Abu D and
he said
and he replied it he
repeated it three times and then he said
and this is the words of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that which we have defined again
and again these negative omens this
is a type of shik this is a type of shik
this is a type of shik and ib said and
there's not one of us except that he
will have this whisper in his heart but
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does away with
it with a so what does that mean? Merely
having the whisper of a shan fleet
through your heart
is not something that you are held to
account for. I mean because we are a
product of our environment
and so because these things have been
driven into our minds so much
we can't help but have this fleeting
whisper of a shaitan go through our
minds and our hearts if a black cat
walks in front of you or any of these
things a mirror is broken or you walk
under a ladder whatever it is right
however what is shik
what is haram
is to believe that thing.
What is haram
is to follow up on the implications
of those beliefs. Right?
So in America for example,
we have things salt. If you knock
over the salt shaker, you need to take a
little bit and throw it over your left
shoulder. This is what we do.
in America because we believe that
this will be bad luck if you don't do
that. Right? And you'll find it even in
cartoons. Right?
Now,
if a person spills this salt
and in their heart it fleets through
their mind that, oh, this is bad luck.
This is not good. But they just pick up
the salt shaker, salt their food and
continue on with their life and dismiss
this whisper of a shaitan. That is the
action of a believer. There's there is
nothing that the person will be held
to account for in that situation.
However, if a person does start to look
for bad luck after this occurrence or if
a person does take the salt and throw
and say, you know, it's silly, but it
doesn't hurt. Well, it very much does
hurt.
It very much it it it is very hurtful to
a person's belief and a person's legacy.
And everything that you do that I do in
this world is ripples in a pond.
You have to remember that. nothing
that we say, nothing that we do
has no consequences. Everything that we
say and do directly affects this world
and directly affects our hereafter.
Right? And this is why Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has gave has given such
importance to the actions and the
statements of the human being.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has angels
documenting every single thing that a
person does or says. Every single human
being no matter who they are, no matter
what their religion is. Why? This is not
because what a person does or says is is
somehow of no consequence. This is
because what we say and do are extremely
consequential.
likewise particular sounds
right or particular sights
that a person may see or hear. We
mentioned we gave an example of the
sound of a crow or the sound of the
sound of a
an owl for instance right that these are
somehow ominous.
Likewise, certain things that happen.
For example, a person would go out in
the morning
and on their way to go do something, on
their way to go see something, they see
a car accident in front of them or
somebody something violent happens or an
altercation. And so they look at this
and they say, ", you know what? I
better call it a day." Why? Because this
is somehow ominous. This is a bad omen.
this means that
something bad is going to happen. This
is a sign that I shouldn't be doing this
or I shouldn't go to this place or this
is all part of
now for this again to fleet through a
person's heart is normal, right? Because
we've been instilled in these things
since our since our adolescence.
However, for you to act upon these
things, for you to believe in these
things, this is where the shik in Allah
subhanahu wa tala starts to take place.
Right? Likewise, particular times,
whether that is a time of day,
a time of the week,
a time of the
year. In America here, we have Friday
the 13th, right? You don't want to get
married on Friday the 13th. They say
you know all horror films and Halloween
and all these things they they
they revolve around a particular date or
time Friday the 13th.
It only happens once a year and this
particular day where the it's the 13th
day of the month and it happens to be a
Friday and that coincides with a Friday.
this is a bad day, right?
, and people do certain things for
this. for example, the first day of
the new year, it's called New Year's
Day.
What people do
is they will have cabbage, for
instance. They say we have to have some
meal having to do with cabbage on the
first day of the new year because this
will give you luck through the rest of
the year.
Right? This is all part of a
now there are many many examples of a
toy in our
popular culture. We'll take some time to
and again this is a very broad topic but
we'll take some time to list some
examples of this. One of these
beliefs is
breaking a mirror
that if a person accidentally breaks a
mirror this gives you how long? Seven
years of bad luck is what they say.
Right? This roots back to the ancient
Romans
and their belief that human life
renewed every seven years, seven-year
cycles, right?
And they viewed the reflection of a
person to be something that is magical.
It's a kind of magical likeness.
And this is why we have a lot of
superstitions connected to mirrors. You
know that vampires, they have no
reflection, right? because they are
evil, they have no soul,
etc. And so if a person breaks a mirror,
well, this articulated in their time,
this necessitated that this person's
reflection, soul, essence, magical
likeness has been shattered. Something
bad is going to happen. And they believe
that this would go on for seven years.
Why? again because of their belief that
every seven years a person's life
cycle you know happens every seven years
and this is of course with regards to
the this all had to do with the cycles
of the moon in their belief in
ancient pagan pagan Rome
and so
They, you know, they would have all
kinds of superstitions in mirrors. Like
for example, many people in ancient
Victoria would not expose their infants
to mirrors. They would not expose their
infants to mirrors
because this was considered something
that is ominous. Likewise, we have in
pop popular culture here in America that
mirrors, you know, , for example,
the idea of the Candyman or the idea of,
you know, these different
things that are going around on social
media, these different challenges or
what have you, that if you look in the
mirror at a certain time, in a certain
day, at a certain way, and you chant a
particular thing in the mirror at night
and blah blah blah, that something will
happen, something will occur. Likewise,
the belief that mirrors somehow
capture souls
is another thing that roots back to
ancient Rome and their pagan beliefs,
right? If you break a mirror, the most
thing you have to worry about is the
sharp glass cutting you, right? How to
clean it up. your wife being upset
with you or your parent or whatever it
is. that is it. Now when a mirror
breaks you break a mirror because we
have grown up in this culture we will
look at it and again that fleeting
thought will go through our mind but
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does away with
that because we don't believe in it and
we have and trust in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and we just proceed with our
lives as usual. This is whispers from a
shaitan. The prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam also gave us something to say
when these things would happen. And that
is
and this is a dua that you can find in
various books of dua. Another one that
is common in America is knocking on
wood. Right? And this goes back to the
superstitions of ancient Scandinavia
where they would believe that trees and
wood would hold particular good spirits,
right? Or it goes back to some
historians mention that this goes back
to belief in
the cross that you know Jesus
according to this belief that the
prophet
they believe was nailed to this cross
and that this wood is somehow something
that we knock on in order to ward off
any bad omens, right? So, when you
mention something bad that happened or
you say, "Well, that hasn't happened to
me or I haven't gotten sick with that or
whatever." And then you knock on wood.
This is a type of shik, right? And this
is a type of worship of other than Allah
[Arabic recitation]
Another example of this was walking
under a ladder. We have that in America.
This goes back to ancient Egypt and
their belief in the triangle and then it
was later transferred into the beliefs
and found its way into the beliefs of
modern Christianity because of their
belief with regards to the triangle and
the trinity. Right? And so if a person
walks under a ladder even if the wa
ladder is only leaning up against the
wall they have essentially broken the
holy trinity. This is bad luck. Now, it
may be good advice from a safety aspect.
You don't want to knock a carpenter off
his ladder. You don't want a ladder
falling on top of you. However, from a
religious standpoint, this is nonsense,
right? , we mentioned spilling of
salt.
We mentioned another one is opening
an umbrella indoors. say that if you
open an umbrella inside
this will give you bad luck, right?
the umbrella for some reason has
always been viewed as some kind of
ominous device. And so we see umbrellas
in modern contemporary media as being
indication of ominous events that are
to take place or usually villains have
umbrellas in comic books and and things
this. And so
you have to be very careful with regards
to opening umbrellas and doors. This is
what they say.
, another one that we have in America
is,
, well, you know, if you're maybe not
in the city, but where I'm from anyways,
, in the Midwest and the South is
horseshoes. We connect a lot of things
to horseshoes. So, a horseshoe is a good
luck. We even have a horseshoe ,
throwing game that we have every year at
different , different
different fairs and so forth. You
always have horseshoe and this goes back
to the U shape with regards to the
crescent. It's connected to the crescent
of the moon. This is something that many
cultures believed in all the way back to
the ancient Egyptians, the Babylonians,
the Hindus, the Selts, right? They
incorporated horseshoes into their
mythology and so forth. , another one
that we have is a rat's foot which we
will speak more about when we discuss
next week inshallah the issue of
talisman's right.
we have a saying this guy or this
woman woke up on the wrong side of
the bed. This is another superstition
that if you climb out of your bed
onto the left side of the bed, even
though left and right of the bed is
subjective
based on your position, but if you
are to get out on the left side, that
this side belongs to the forces of death
and destruction and that the right side
of the bed
the this this belongs to the
forces of light and good. ,
, hotel and casino designers
have incorporated this into their hotel
rooms
to the point that
, the left side of the bed is always
facing the wall to force you to get up
on the right side of the bed, right?
, why is that? Because you're in a
casino and you want to wear money. You
want to win money. And so winning money,
you have to get up on which side of the
bed. This obviously is shik and and and
nonsense. But
in ancient European customs
a person must get up on a particular
side of the bed and that is the side
that they went to sleep on. Right? And
so we always speak about someone who's
in a bad mood. We say, "Oh, he must have
gotten up on the wrong side of the bed
today." that comes from that ancient
belief.
Another one which is very common amongst
Muslims is wearing black when you are
mourning. Right? The color black is
considered to be a color of death, a
color of mourning. And that is exactly
the opposite of what that color
represents in the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's tradition and the
conquest of Mecca. It was mentioned that
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam wore a black turban and the
conquest of Mecca is considered to be
one of the greatest
one of the best and greatest events for
the good of mankind in the Arab
Peninsula at that time. And so when you
go to,
you know, the the color of black, it
actually goes back to
belief in ancient China, in Persia, in
these different areas that death is
somehow contagious. This is what they
believed.
And so
when a person wears black, it's somehow
wards off this contagion. This is
where it roots back to. But now it's
become a color of sadness, a color of
death, that death is always black.
and so when a person is mourning or goes
to a funeral must wear black and this is
again type of superstition is definitely
haram in Islam and many Muslims do it.
This is something that we have taken up
and so in Chinese funerals you find that
they go to the funerals wearing white.
They go to the funerals wearing white
because they believe that death is
somehow contagious and wearing black
would somehow track that. Exactly the
opposite. We mentioned black cats. We
mentioned the number 13. these are
types of superstitions which are
common in in our demographic.
You you have as well things like
broomsticks, right? Jump over a
broomstick, you'll have bad luck. ,
we have other sayings such as
find a penny, pick it up all day you'll
have good luck. ,
, find a penny, leave it lay, bad luck
you'll have all day. That's what we used
to say when we were kids growing up in
America. Likewise, , if you step on a
crack, you'll break your mother's back.
These are silly things that we say now.
However, these are actually all rooted
back to ancient paganism, ancient
idolatry, and these things all fall into
the general
prohibition of
holding these beliefs and acting upon
the implications of these beliefs.
if you go into
they also believe that certain kinds of
animals will bring good luck will do the
opposite. So if you go into Chinese
stores, Chinese restaurants,
invariably you will find a cat made out
of porcelain with either the right or
left paw up and it usually moves and
this is to attract wealth and attract
good. they actually use particular
numbers as well, right? the lucky
number seven or the lucky number of
21 or any of these other things. Another
thing that people say in in in America,
third time is a charm, right? This is
also goes back to this ancient
far east Asian beliefs in numbers
numerology, right? And we have
paradoxically exactly the opposite and
that is that bad luck comes in sets of
three, right? So if a person sneezes
three times, this is a bad omen, right?
If they sneeze too, it's okay, right?
likewise, if a person has something
bad happen, you need to look out for two
more bad things that are going to happen
because bad luck comes in in in
groups of three, numbers of three. All
of this is not correct. unfortunately
in Islam, we take other things and we do
the exact opposite.
So for example,
if you go to take a date, people believe
that you need to take three dates. You
can't just take two. You either take one
date or you take three dates or you take
five dates, right? It has to be w and
they'll insist and tell you,
you know, this as well has no foundation
in Islamic law.
one day, two, 10, whatever fills your
belly, whatever doesn't make you sick,
whatever is not is this is what a
person should take. There is no evidence
of this anywhere in the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
and so on and so forth.
So that is enough for today.
Inshallah, next week we will be
discussing talismans and lucky charms.
not the not the cereal. However,
we probably could discuss that as well.
,
He was higher than he